today on the matt walsh show we're going
to have an uncomfortable conversation
about race another one
though it shouldn't be uncomfortable at
all really because all i'm going to do
is give you the facts about interracial
violence and homicide
the media is telling you lies so today
we'll look at the truth also five
headlines including
utah's move to protect children from
pornography the mayor of charlottesville
goes
entirely insane and a soccer player is
the latest
spoiled rich woman to publicly announce
that she's oppressed
in our daily cancellation we'll deal
with a few recent examples of alleged
anti-asian racism
but are they really examples of racism
at all my answer will
well not shock you at all but we'll talk
about that and much more today on the
matt walsh show
[Applause]
the events of the last few weeks seem to
have sparked a renewed conversation
about the threat posed by in the words
of a recent
usa today headline white violence
these concerns which are being expressed
in spite of the fact that the atlanta
shooter was not motivated by race and
the boulder shooter wasn't even white
though all of his victims were
all stemmed from an alleged pandemic of
white brutality in the words of another
headline a quick trip through google
will pull up countless articles and
editorials with phrases like
white rage and weaponized whiteness and
the threat of whiteness
as kamela harris's niece mina harris put
it in a now deleted tweet
violent white men are the greatest
terror threat to our country
the website m live in michigan has a
story this week about black people in
michigan who are
afraid to walk through the suburbs for
fear of violence
from whites in michigan
it's reported that increasing numbers of
black people are purchasing guns in
order to defend themselves
against dastardly white men now the
message from all this is clear
white people are dangerous and uniquely
so
we're meant to believe or at least to
shut up and pretend we believe that
white violence is a serious problem
in this country and that much of that
violence is interracial
now as the media tries its hardest to
stir up panic over the hordes of
murderous bloodthirsty white men
supposedly
roaming our streets it becomes necessary
to introduce some truth and sanity into
the picture
fortunately the fbi for the time being
at least until the
woke mob demands that they take it down
has homicide statistics organized into
handy charts and available on their
website you can go
look at it yourself a look at those
charts shows first
that the vast majority of murder is
intra-racial
that is in the lion's share of cases one
member of a race is killing another
member of the same race
so in 2019 there were 3 299 white
victims of murder
of which 2594 were killed by other white
people
there were 2 906 black victims of murder
of which 2574 were killed by
other black people given the sort of
wanton
slaughter between races and ethnicities
that you find in other parts of the
world and throughout other periods in
history it's quite remarkable
actually how little interracial violence
we actually have in this country
though the race-baiters on the left are
doing what they can to change that
as for inter-interracial murder
that is murder between different races
the statistics just as clearly show that
whites fall victim
to that far more often than any other
race
in 2019 566 whites were killed by blacks
as opposed
to 246 blacks killed by whites the
numbers are very similar throughout all
other years in recent history again you
can go look at this yourself
outlets like reuters have run fact
checks on memes and social media posts
that make exactly the claim that i just
made
which is based entirely on publicly
available fbi data
and reuters determined that the claims
are somehow still false
or at least misleading maybe they'll say
that about what i'm maybe this this what
i'm doing right now
is going to get a fact check if they're
going to say it's wrong now how do they
do that well
they explain that though it's true that
more white people fall victim to
interracial murder it's also true
that given the population disparities
black people are more likely to fall
victim to interracial murder
now that's technically correct though
it's nonsensical to accuse someone of
stating a falsehood just because they
didn't
frame the statistical data in the way
that you
subjectively prefer you take any
data point there are different ways of
framing it
all of which could be true what the fact
checkers on the internet will do
is they have one particular framing that
they want to see
and if you don't frame it that way
they're gonna they're gonna they're
going to fact check you and say that
what you're saying is false
even if it's true
the problem though is that the more
likely knife cuts both ways
see if we say that blacks are more
likely to fall victims than whites
we must also say that blacks again given
the difference in population size
are significantly more likely to
victimize whites
any given black person is more likely to
die by violence even violence from a
white person
but he's also more likely to be the one
committing violence
that's what the statistics indisputably
show
those are just the facts that's it
there's no way to frame the numbers that
will get around the simple facts of the
matter
the problem of interracial violence in
america though comparatively small and
we should be grateful for that
is a problem being driven much more by
non-white people than by white people
non-white people are committing
the majority of interracial violence and
also intra-racial violence
and it's not even that close if black
people in michigan
or anywhere else are running to arm
themselves for fear of homicidal whites
that fear is purely the product of media
fabrication
it has no foundation in reality none
what's the point of presenting this
information why bother citing fbi fbi
homicide statistics
well because first of all the truth
matters i think i think it matters for
its own sake
when someone like jessica valenti claims
as she did in a post on medium
that quote young white male rage is the
biggest threat to our country
she has no facts supporting her
whatsoever
she has only her feelings her
perceptions what she wishes were true
what she thinks ought to be true
truth again matters for its own sake and
must be asserted
and asserted again and reasserted in the
face of lies and false narratives and we
must
keep absurding it asserting it every
single time
also and this is really important
we have to consider why these lies are
being told
it should make us suspicious and quite
worried whenever we notice that
any racial or ethnic group is being
assigned the role
of bad guys it's what's happening right
now to white people white males in
particular
humanity has a long history of doing
this sort of thing of positioning
a certain category of humans as the
societal
scapegoats and we've seen the terrifying
results of that
time and time and time again
and when it becomes taboo to defend that
group
from the false narratives used to
slander it when the average person
slightly recoils and kind of grimaces at
the presentation of factual information
as some of you may have done when i was
just telling you the fbi homicide
statistics
some of you when you were listening
might have been like
i don't know if you should be saying
this
well when even average people have that
reaction to the truth
that's when you know that we've truly
entered the danger zone
our cultural overlords have their
reasons for lying about the great white
menace
the reasons cannot be good and they
cannot lead to anything
but horror and suffering and hate
that after all for them is the whole
point
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
today i want to tell you about one of
our sponsors true
underdog podcast you know raised in a
trailer park with no clear path to
success kicked out of high school
multiple times and faced with becoming a
father as teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog after hearing him with the
words no or you can't too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing
on a path to becoming a billion dollar
enterprise you could join us as
waller a four-time entrepreneur of the
year um shares motivational tips and
inspiring stories and business building
lessons from the ground up he shares his
life experiences and that of his high
profile guest to help others
better themselves as well as waller will
tell you there's no elevator to success
you know you gotta
climb one step at a time let every true
underdog podcast
be that step that elevates you you learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
gotta check out this podcast and
experience the whole thing so
go check out the true underdog podcast
and you can find that at
trueunderdog.com
or anywhere that you happen to get your
podcast
uh i i feel like kind of a hypocrite
because i'm always complaining about
pets
and saying on this show and you know on
twitter
because it's a very important issue that
people shouldn't have
beasts they should have they shouldn't
have hairy beasts now you could say that
i'm a hairy beast but uh but i'm a human
so
they shouldn't have non-human hairy
beasts in their home uh and yet
we have a cat right now it's not really
my cat's my wife's cat she's the one
who insisted that we get it and the deal
was when she brought the cat home the
deal was okay
i will tolerate the cat being in the
house but i'm not gonna take
care of the of this animal you have to
do everything i'm not gonna do it that's
the deal
otherwise i'm not getting like i'm not
volunteering to do anything for the cat
um now i didn't know see there was the
loophole that wasn't made clear to me
from the beginning but
the loophole is that um when a woman is
pregnant
she can't change a litter box because
there's a disease that you can get from
the cat
feces that can cause birth defects and
um and my wife
you know we've had we have four kids we
had four kids since when we got the cat
so i've spent much of the time
cleaning the litter box i'm kind of
convinced that that's part of the reason
we had
that my wife wanted to have the kids is
just to get out of the litter box
duties but anyway um so yesterday
so we have this cat yesterday my my
daughter
who's been around this cattle literally
her whole life uh suddenly developed
allergies an
allergic reaction to the cat which we're
told can happen just one day
she's allergic never was before now she
is and um
you know she had this allergy we got the
medicine for it but when i got home and
i was talking to my daughter about it
and i told her i said we you know we can
just get rid of it
i mean we can give it to someone or
whatever we don't have to just look we
don't have to keep the cat
around because he's the cat's trying to
kill you we can and my daughter
doesn't want to do she wants to keep the
cat it just shows like
these animals this is it's all a long
way to get to the moral of the story
here
this is a message from nature
a message from god i would say telling
us
you shouldn't have animals in your home
you can get diseases from the poop
that will cause birth defects they're
trying to kill your children
with their whatever causes allergies
and we just we put up with it no one can
no one knows why why do we put up with
this
what do we get out of this what do we
get i know what the cat gets out of
being allowed in our home
what are we getting out of this what do
we get out of this deal
never got to answer that question all
right okay
um number one from the daily wire
republican governor of utah spencer cox
signed a controversial piece of
legislation on tuesday requiring all
smartphones and tablets sold in utah to
have filters
that can block pornography governor cox
has said that the proposal would send an
important message about prohibiting
children from gaining access to explicit
online material the bill states it would
require a smartphone or tablet sold in
utah and made on or after january 1st of
the year following the year this bill
takes effect
to when activated in the state
automatically enable a filter capable of
blocking material that is harmful to
miners
the filter on the device must prevent
the user of the device from accessing
material that is harmful to miners on
the device enable
certain users to deactivate the filter
for the device for specific content and
notify the user when content is filtered
um you know and that's that's the i
think
yeah it's controversial because we lived
in
a porn obsessed society and many people
their porn habit is sacred to them and
anything
that can present any obstacle to getting
to porn
for a lot of people in this country
because they're addicted to it uh
any obstacle they consider to be a
horrific affront against them and
against their human rights
because what would be the reason for
objecting to this
you want to look at porn you still look
at it it's not going to stop you
just you got the filter you got to
change the settings or whatever
is that too much of an effort but people
are opposed to it
the whole idea and this to me now you
know how i feel about porn i'd be in
favor of banning it out right
um so this is one little baby step in
the right direction
i'm fully in favor of it
and the point here is to protect
children and what we have to remember
is that children and i know we're
getting away from this in a big way in
society we talk about dangerous trends
a lot of dangerous trends when it comes
to race as we talked about
a lot of dangerous trends here too when
it comes to children and our ideas of
consent
but traditionally what we've always
known
and what is not just traditionally true
but actually true is that
children can't consent they don't have
the psychological ability
to fully consent to anything really
especially a sexual act
um looking at pornography is in effect a
sexual act
you you are you are you are becoming a
participant
a a third-party participant in this
sexual act
as a viewer children can't consent to
that
they don't have the ability to consent
to it so if this stuff is made available
to them
they are victims the moment a child is
exposed to pornography
they didn't they cannot you could say
well they chose to look no they can't
choose they cannot choose to look at it
even if they choose they didn't really
choose it because they can't consent
and choices about consent they can't do
it
so we can't expect them we can't expect
children to guard
their own hearts and minds when it comes
to pornography
we have to put the filters in place to
protect them
and i don't want to hear anything about
oh it's the parents job
if your parents should do it i agree the
parents should be doing it
that so what that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't take other steps as well
yes parents should be protecting the
kids from this but number one a lot of
parents don't and so what are we saying
about those kids
too bad there are millions of kids in
this country
their parents should be protecting them
parents are not and so our message on
porn is well too bad so what
those kids they'll be exposed to
hardcore pornography at the age of eight
years old and be psychologically ruined
by it
um not too bad we're not gonna do
anything for them
parents didn't help you out kid sorry
that's the attitude yeah that is the
attitude of a lot of people i find it
i find it morally deranged
and absolutely indefensible
because the only reason you're taking
that position is just because you love
looking at porn you don't want to be
interfered with
so a lot of kids have parents who don't
protect them and then also
uh they're they're it is not possible
a parent can only do so much to protect
their kid from this stuff
it is so ubiquitous and this stuff is
out there everywhere
if your kid leaves your site at all
which at a certain point he's going to
he's going to be around his friends are
going to have phones there's going to be
laptops and stuff
he's going to his friend's house he
doesn't have to go to his friend's house
anymore right
he could just go outside and be walking
with his friend the friend pulls out
the phone and looks at it like there's
only so much that you as a protective
parent can do
there's a lot you can do but you can't
do everything
yet more reason to put measures in place
to to beyond parent what the parent can
do to help these kids
it's like the analogy that i use of um
you know think about buying pornography
the old-fashioned way
the way they used to do the in the old
days going to a you know the gas station
buying a porn magazine or something now
um what if a kid
went in you know 10 year old kid goes
into a gas station pulls a porn mag off
of the rack
um and goes to buy it
it would be illegal for the cashier to
sell that magazine to the child
now you can say what's that kid doing at
a gas station by himself where that
kid's parents
it's the parent's job to make sure the
kid's not buying a porn mag
true you're right yes but
for whatever reason the parents aren't
there right now um the kid is there
so does that mean that the cashier
should just sell it to him
the fact that the parent isn't there is
that an excuse is that a good reason
is that justification for the cashier to
make the decision to sell that magazine
i would hope you would say no
even if this kid has neglect neglectful
or negligent parents
especially if he has negligent parents
still you can't sell in the magazine
you're committing a crime if you do
see you as the gas station the person at
the gas station
selling this material the onus is on you
to put measures in place to make sure
that kids are not obtaining this stuff
you you can't do everything either there
are ways around it for kid but
there are some basic measures we expect
you to put in place as the person who is
offering this stuff
to protect kids why don't we have the
same requirements of porn sites
we have zero required you understand
that zero
right now there are zero requirements
for porn sites
in terms of um
uh of of protecting kids and making sure
that they're not
giving their product to children they
zero we don't expect anything of them
we expect more of the cashier at the gas
station
than we do of like pornhub
once again indefensible makes no sense
at all and i i've never heard a defense
for this
other than i've heard a lot of defenses
but they all seem to boil down to
the person saying it what they're really
saying is i like porn and
you know i i don't want to think about
it anymore than that and i don't want
anything to interfere with me looking at
porn
all right number two amber athy works
for the spectator and she has this
report she says
governor christie gnome's office says in
an email that she's a victim of
conservative cancel culture
and adds that she's not caving to the
ncaa but that the bill picked the fight
with the ncaa a fight that renowned
conservative legal experts advise
governor gnome
that she will lose and then uh the
office continues to continue by saying
if conservative media would take five
seconds to read past the knee-jerk
headlines and actually understand
governor noam's position
they'd come to a very different
realization okay let me say two things
briefly
uh number one this is not cancel culture
okay let's let's let's not misuse cancel
culture it's already misused enough
this is a useful term it means something
it's a very real phenomenon that's
happening in the culture
uh and it's important and it and and we
need to be able to talk about it
and if you're using it in a context like
this you are helping to make this
into a you know a term that has no
meaning like so many other terms now
so many once useful terms now have no
meaning because the way that they've
been
used and misused and overused this is
not cancelled culture
you're the governor of the state you've
made a decision
that your base doesn't like and they're
expressing that they don't like it
that's not cancel culture
i gotta say governor gnome is impressing
me less and less with each given day
now you're whining that even if they're
wrong let's just say for the sake of
argument that you you're right
and the base including me we're all
wrong it's cancel culture because we're
disagreeing with you
you're not getting thrown out of office
you made a decision that we don't like
and we're telling you the people of your
state are telling you that i like it
stop you're canceling me oh come on
and this thing about renowned legal
experts
shut up with that you cannot use
the authority of a legal expert
to convince us that what you're doing is
right if you won't even tell us who the
experts are
you know governor gnome rightly and
bravely stood up against this kind of
nonsense when it came to uh covid and
the lockdowns and everything
and you had the pro lockdown people
saying all the experts all the experts
say we should lock down
well now governor nolan's doing the
exact same damn thing
except it's even worse now because we
don't even know who these experts are
she's not telling us
all she's telling us is that she talked
to a lot of experts and they said this
was the right thing to do
no it's your if you're going to use
experts as your justification
it's your responsibility to tell us who
these experts are
so that we can consult those experts or
at least
can vet them ourselves so we can know
who these people are
and decide if we should take their
opinion seriously or not
number three nakuya walker is the mayor
of charlottesville
and um she posted a bizarre
something i don't know exactly what this
is or is supposed to be
but she posted this to social media
yesterday uh and she posted it i guess
when i say social media all of her
social media posts on instagram
twitter facebook she was very proud of
this and she wanted people to see it
and what it said was i'm just going to
read it
this is the thing that she was the mayor
of charlottesville and this is what she
posted
charlottesville the beautiful ugly it is
it rapes you comforts you in its
blank stained sheet and tells you to
keep it secret
now i have to say
these tourism campaigns are getting
really edgy um
this is not i don't know if
you know that someone is the city they
the tourism department came to the mayor
and say listen mayor you know
we're not getting a lot of visitors here
charlottesville there's been a lockdown
there's been a lot of bad
publicity uh we got to get we got to
think of a a
tourism campaign we need something to
put on the billboards put on
uh bumper stickers put in the ads
advertisements and this is what she came
up with
charlottesville it rapes you and
comforts you
i gotta say i i i think it needs a
little work you gotta
you right this is why you really should
be hi
speaking of experts maybe a couple
marketing get some marketing people in
there
and i'm no marketing expert but i don't
know if this is the way to go now
later on um she
posted the longer version of what she
now says is a poem
and that's what the original thing was
this was what she had posted what i just
read was the short version
sort of like a haiku um
and a short version of the longer poem
and here's the longer one and this one
she posted again to i think twitter
facebook
instagram post it all over the place
very proud of it
here's the longer version this again is
the the mayor of the city of
charlottesville
this is what she posted charlottesville
the beautiful ugly it is and uh sidebar
i i don't know what that means the
beautiful ugly it is
what is that supposed to mean um the
beautiful ugly it is
it lynched you hung the noose at city
hall and pressed the souvenir that was
once your finger against its lips
it covers your death with its good
intentions it is a place where white
women with black kids collect signatures
for a white man who questions whether a
black woman
understands white supremacy it is
destructively world class
white people say that it is a place
where gentrification started with the
election of a black woman in 2017
and because of white power a lie becomes
hashtag facts
you always gotta put the hashtag in your
poetry that's how you know it's really
poetic
it's daily practice is that of
separating you from your soul
charlottesville is void of a moral
compass
this is the mayor of the city talking
about the city she leads
it's as good old it is as if good old tj
thomas jefferson is still cleverly using
his whip to whip the current inhabitants
into
submissiveness charlottesville rapes you
of your breaths
it suffocates your hopes and dreams it
liberates you
by conveniently redefining liberation
it progressively chants while it
conservatively acts
charlottesville is anchored in white
supremacy and rooted in racism
charlottesville rapes you and covers you
in sullied sheets
now she posted that and she said um
she she wanted to know is this better
like are you people still is this better
than the short version and the answer
mayor is no
uh really i gotta tell you it's not any
better uh significantly worse in fact
than the original thing
and and i mean there's there's so much
to be said
about this one one really doesn't know
where to begin um maybe i'll i'll only
say this and we'll move on that
you know what does it tell you
that this this is the kind of person
that democrat voters select to run their
cities
maybe that maybe maybe we can learn why
these cities run by democrats and when i
say cities run by democrats i mean like
i don't know
all of them are in shambles
because they're being run by people who
hate
the city and hate most of the people in
the city
she says charlottesville suffocates your
hopes and dreams
now there you go that is the quote for
the billboard
charlottesville will suffocate your
hopes and dreams
thanks for stopping by you'll never
leave
um she's the mayor of the city and it's
not like she was just elected i think
she'd been the mayor for a couple years
and she still hates it
you you cannot lead uh a city
that you that you hate you cannot be a
leader
to people that you hate
i am not saying you have to have some
utopian
view of your city obviously you have to
realize it's problems but if you despise
it
and hate it as she obviously does
you're not going to be able to be a good
leader and also if you're
if you're if you're psychotic you're not
going to be a good leader and she's also
clearly psychotic so we got a couple
problems there
all adds up to um some real some real
leadership difficulties
gotta get her some leadership training
classes okay um number four so yesterday
was equal pay day i think like the
the fourth equal pay day of the year i
believe we get a bunch of them now
um we got a bunch of women's days
women's
history months international women's
month international women's day
international women's week equal pay day
the next equal payday so a lot of
different
things like that joe biden
celebrated the occasion by making a
pretty remarkable claim let's listen to
it here's joe biden
i've told my daughters granddaughters
from the time
they were old enough to understand what
i was saying
and i mean it there's not a single thing
a man can do that a woman can't do as
well or better
not a single thing i was among the first
senators ever to appoint a woman to the
naval academy
i was just able to as president united
states
appoint two women as four-star generals
okay first of all joe you say your
grandchildren
once they were old enough to understand
you um nobody is old enough to
understand
you nobody understands anything that
you're saying
and also speak for yourself
there's nothing a woman can do there's
nothing a man can do that a woman can't
do as well or better speak for yourself
i believe that that's true of you i
totally believe that's true of you but
um
beyond that it really makes no sense i
mean first of all you should see my wife
try to parallel park
so let's start with that and then go to
like you know
bench press more than 150 pounds um so
there are many things we could list
obviously
that makes no sense that statement is
totally factually incorrect
though if if you believe that a male
can be a woman then i guess it could be
true if you believe that though the
statement becomes
meaningless at that point um
and then we had megan rapinoe who is the
women's soccer player and after joe
biden she took the stage
to talk about how she's being oppressed
now we already know we've heard a lot
from um
spoiled rich women who are oppressed uh
meghan markle
oftentimes their name is megan actually
and meghan markle uh
deeply deeply oppressed in her 15
million
mansion megan rapido also oppressed and
here she'll tell us why
i'm a member of the lgbtq community
with pink hair and where i come from i
could have only dreamed that i would be
standing in the position i am today at
the white house
i'm also a professional athlete and i've
helped
along with all of my teammates virtually
here
today one teammate literally here today
uh win
four world cup championships and four
olympic gold medals for the united
states
and despite those wins i've been
devalued
i've been disrespected and dismissed
because i am a woman
and i've been told that i don't deserve
any more than less
because i am a woman
you see despite all the wins i'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that i do
oh you poor woman what a what a you you
poor
poor helpless girl i guess that's the
reaction you want right you want us to
pity you
what you're looking for if you want us
to patronize and pity you megan then
fine you'll get it
your poor little child your poor little
girl
just shut up you you
you're at the freaking white house
speaking
um you're a rich athlete
world renowned
it's still not enough not enough for you
people don't appreciate you enough
you've been doubted because you're pink
hair
if you don't like the comments your pink
hair then then dye it a different color
the reason that you haven't gotten paid
the same
as some of the male athletes is that
women's soccer doesn't bring in
that much money because not a lot of
people watch it
because most people find it to be boring
like i do
now they might say otherwise they might
they might
theoretically support it they might
support women's sports in theory
they like the idea of women playing
sports and
they think that women should be paid the
same
most of the people saying that are not
actually watching the games
if they were watching the games you get
paid the same as the men because you'd
be bringing in all that money but you're
not
because the money's not there male
athletes get paid more
because more people are interested and
that's it
now you could shout at everybody for not
being more into
that's your real gripe here your real
problem is not that you're not getting
paid the same
your real problem is that people just
aren't all that interested
in the women's sports at least not not
interested enough to be spectators
which is where the money is right and um
and so that's what you're mad about but
you can't shout at people to make them
be interested in something
you could try but it's not going to work
you can scream at them all you want be
interested in this i demand it
i demand that you be interested in women
playing soccer
you could do that but it's not going to
change anything it's only going to make
people less interested
so that that's the issue that you're
having but even in spite of all that
megan
you still are making a living playing a
game
you know most people can't even dream of
that most people dream of it but it will
never happen for them
you're literally living out so many
people's wildest dreams
and you're rich and famous and you're at
the white house and the president is on
your side
my god how about a little bit of
gratitude for a change instead of
whining
how about be grateful for what you've
been given for what this country has
made possible
this country that you despise that you
hate
it has yet given you all of this
simply to play a game and you've been
able to carve out a spot
playing a game even though you know
even though a moderately talented high
school boy
it would be a better soccer player than
you
and the reason i know that by the way is
that you were beat by
by high school boys under the age of 15.
you were beat by a bunch of 14 year old
boys
and i wouldn't even usually bring that
up because yeah you're you're a woman
they're they're guys they have the
advantage
but when you go whining you're not
getting paid the same as men you got
beat by
14 year old boys and in spite of that
you still get to be
a world famous athlete richer than most
people will ever
could ever imagine themselves being and
all you could do is whine and complain
i i think it's just disgraceful
it's it is more than annoying it's
actually infuriating
but fine maybe that should be our policy
from now on if these people want to be
patronized and pitied
then let's patronize and pity them
that's what they want
joe biden's up there women can do
anything that men can do
a woman like with her head on her
shoulders
uh would would
is is angry at that because it's so
patronizing
you're treating me like a child i know
that's not true
self-respecting woman that's going to be
her reaction to that kind of nonsense
but megan rampino she loves it
she's not self-respecting clearly and
she wants to be patronized too
all right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments uh this is from ellen
welsh she says cinnamon toast crunch is
delivered to us in the hands of fat
cherubs from heaven sir
heaven no alan salmon toast french as i
made clear
is is not for uh the age limit on that
is
for is 14 i'll say you know
right when you're at the age where
you're beating um the olympic
women's soccer team you know like right
at that age that's sort of the cutoff
and also you're banned from the show
unfortunately for that infraction
another one says matt absolutely love
the cancellation segment you rant on and
on and i just can't wait for the
dramatic they are cancelled part you
have perfected the deep stern voice and
icy stare into the camera
wow just wow also i agree i agree with
you that every voter should have to take
a basic knowledge test
just like you do to get your driver's
license well
thank you for watching the show i'm not
going to ban you for that
um i'm always looking for any excuse and
that you didn't give me one because it
was nothing but nice things
mark says matt the daily wire should
officially change its name to the daily
joy
because of the immeasurable joy i get
every single day from tuning in best
money i ever spent godspeed
you're not supposed to get joy mark
um despair that's really what i'm going
for here
joy is not it so sadly you're banned
from the show
um another one says i've been watching
the matt wall show a couple months and
i've made it a priority to watch every
day oh so you only started watching a
couple months ago
why didn't why were you watching it
before then what were you doing
i mean i've been doing this for a couple
years you just started watching a couple
months ago well
obviously you got to be banned for that
finally cali says matt while looking at
my reading list i realize something is
missing i have books by ben
andrew and candace and michaels is on
pre-order any plans for a book of your
own
no pressure but i would definitely buy
and read it love the show
i've written two books you know
um done holy trinity and and the church
of cowards
you didn't know that i wrote two books
well you know what happens now banned
from the show
but those are the books though you can
buy them unholy trinity and
church of cowards thanks for asking one
thing we can agree on as conservatives
in theory allegedly is that we all love
the constitution
it's what we all say anyway right that
we're constitutional conservatives you
rarely hear from a non-constitutional
conservative
um but the problem is that few of us
have actually studied it
um and even fewer stand ready to defend
it that's what my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com are all about
they've got a lot of great programs for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying and living out the constitution
and i just i've been telling you about
the the constitutional defense course
that i experienced this past weekend
first of all if i can have fun doing it
then you know that that you can so
my bar is pretty high for having fun but
it's not just about having fun you also
are learning
really important skills and i walked
away from my experience
feeling much much more comfortable
handling a firearm ready to defend
myself
my family than i ever was before you get
an amazing combination of intellectual
ammunition and live classes with
rick green america's constitution coach
and then you also get the physical
training at the premier firearms
facility in the nation all in the same
course you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation
so you're learning and training you also
get that fellowship with like-minded
people and you get that experience of
knowing that but they're not you're not
alone out there there are other people
just like us
which sometimes can come as a revelation
uh so you gotta go to
constitutioncoach.com rick and the
constitution coach team have another
class on april 25th but it'll fill up
fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today and watch my
video there to find out more about how
you can be a part of this one-of-a-kind
training
constitutioncoach.com and listen if you
um
haven't heard by now the candace owens
show is uh is is happening it's it's
live it's happening
campus owns has a brand new talk show
with us exclusively at dailywire.com the
full show is available
at dailywire.com for daily wire members
but candace
the podcast is available on apple and
you can or you can get on spotify
anywhere you get your podcast
and i would recommend that because the
canvas podcast features several breakout
segments from the full-length show
including interviews panel discussions
and her advice corner
the podcast is is really good so is the
full show
so make sure you go apple podcast
spotify wherever you get your podcast
and subscribe today and be sure to leave
a five star review
so um so they know that uh you like
hearing
everything they have to offer there now
let's get to our daily cancellation
so today we must go on another
cancellation spree just like the banning
spree that i
that i just went on canceling a whole
line of people i
don't like having to do it you know it
hurts me more than it hurts you but i
have to
i've been left no choice today the
cancellations will all focus on the
issue of fake anti-asian racism which
has been
a common theme over the past few weeks
so we must now give our attention to
some especially egregious examples
and we'll start with megan mccain who
issued an apology this week for
previously using the term
china virus in referencing covet
this apology came after john oliver the
most overrated brit since
john lennon called her out for her
alleged anti-asian racism
and mccain related to that and she
issued a statement an apology and it
said i condemn the reprehensible
violence and vitriol that has been
targeted towards the asian american
community
there is no doubt donald trump's racist
rhetoric fueled many of these attacks
and i apologize for any past comments
that aided that agenda
never mind that there is no evidence at
all that trump's rhetoric has fueled any
attacks on asians
the greater point is that she had
nothing to apologize for in fact mccain
never even used the term china virus
herself actually as far as i know
she merely said that she doesn't mind
when trump uses it
and that statement uttered by a host on
the view is supposed to have somehow
helped to inspire a massacre at a
massage parlor
so she's on the view and says yeah i
don't mind when he says it
and that somehow contributed to a guy
shooting up a massage power parlor
what that makes no sense
you're being defamed slandered
rather than say that it makes no sense
and defend yourself
you apologize meanwhile a massively
viral twitter thread from a woman named
michelle kim
pronouns in the bio so you know this
will be good the threat explains why
it's racist to mispronounce
asian names she writes quote
why the name thing is so triggering to
me and many other agents
a thread i spent my entire adult life in
the u.s by my nickname michelle because
i hated dealing with the burden of
correcting people each time they got my
name wrong
i hated the shame i felt every new
school year when the teacher would
butcher my korean name on the roster
if you went to a school with a lot of
asian kids you know the drill
teacher mispronounced his asian name
asian student uh i go by peter
other kids chuckle when my grandma
passed last month we had
we had to correct the memorial service
people multiple times to get her first
and last name written correctly
half of her first name kept being
written in the middle name section
on her death certificate marker
everywhere it was exhausting these might
be small conveniences
inconveniences to people but our names
are our are
our identity it's our heritage it's what
we have left that reminds us who we are
where we come from
my grandpa gave me my korean name it has
a beautiful origin and meaning
i'm ashamed i don't use it today
okay so um
use it then i mean whose fault is that
well of course it's everyone's fault but
your own
as for mispronouncing asian names that's
not racist it's also not anything that
we should have to apologize for i don't
apologize for mispronouncing anyone's
name
asian or not it's not something that you
do on purpose
you you mis you mispronounce it it's an
accident it happens
like when i mispronounce camila harris's
name totally
it's a total accident i don't mean to do
it every time
asian names are um unusual in the west
right and they're difficult for us to
pronounce because they use sounds that
aren't common in our language
the same goes in the reverse many
english words and names
are difficult for many asians to
pronounce because our language uses
sounds
that aren't common in their language i
could never imagine moving to a foreign
country on the other side of the world
and then getting mad at them having the
gumption
the gall to be mad at them because they
struggle to pronounce
my extremely unusual name extremely
unusual to them
that is i mean what is their actual sin
what am i blaming them for
am i angry at them simply for being
asian simply for having their langu
their language and not mine isn't that
racist on my part
by the way one other note i have no
doubt that michelle kim and other asians
experienced some bullying in school when
kids laughed at and snickered at
their unusual names unusual to them to
the other kids
in this country i have no doubt you know
that that happened and i have no doubt
that it was tough to deal with as a
child
i i i'm sure that's the case but you're
not a child anymore
it's time to move past that get over it
guess what
everybody got laughed at and picked on
for something in school there was
something about everyone
that was deemed unusual and strange to
the other kids and they laughed about it
if it wasn't your name it was some
physical
feature if it wasn't that it was some
personality quirk if it wasn't that it
was something else
how you dressed whatever anything
we all got it we all dealt with it
you're not different you're not special
you're the same as everybody else
time to move on you're an adult now
and also you're canceled but there's one
more jay leno um
variety reports this says quote late
night hosted comedian jay leno has
issued an apology for a series of jokes
told over his career targeting asian
communities the apology comes
after a nearly 15-year campaign from the
activist group media action
that is media action network for asian
americans for remarks as recent as
varieties 2020 report that leno cracked
about
um koreans eating dog meat a a a
complaint that offended numerous players
in the set of nbc's america's got talent
at the time and this is leno now talking
at the time i did those jokes i
genuinely thought
that they were harmless i was making fun
of our enemy north korea and like most
jokes there was a ring of truth to them
leno continued at the time there was a
prevailing attitude that some group is
always complaining about something so
don't worry about it
whenever we received a complaint there
would be two sides of the discussion
either
we need to deal with this or screw them
if they can't take a joke too many times
i sided with the ladder even when
in my heart i knew it was wrong in light
of that leno said quote i am
issuing this apology i do not consider
this particular case to be another
example of canceled culture but a
legitimate wrong
that was done on my part manna has been
very gracious and accepting my apology i
hope that the asian-american community
will be able to accept it as well and i
hope i can live up to their expectations
in the future
now apparently nearly all of the
anti-asian jokes were about asians
eating dog meat
and that's what lena was apologizing for
but he was right the first time see he
was right
when he had the screw him if they don't
take they can't take a joke attitude
that's the right idea that's also the
only attitude a comedian can have if he
wishes to remain a comedian
as for jokes about asians eating dogs
well when we put this delicately
asians do eat dogs it's a little less
common now than it used to be
but it's still very common the bbc has a
report on their website from 2017 titled
the countries where people still eat
cats and dogs for dinner and it says
citing the humane society international
that quote
an estimated 30 million dogs across asia
including stolen family pets are still
killed
for human consumption every year 30
million
so asians eat dogs that's a factual
statement
not all asians of course but it's a
stereotype
firmly grounded in reality what's racist
here
is it racist to point it out is it
racist simply to notice
what is true so is the bbc racist for
reporting on this incident at all
or this fact at all or is it racist to
joke about what's true
what else are you to joke about jokes
about what isn't true
aren't very funny you know when
someone's making
observational humor and they're
observing something that isn't true
you're not going to laugh about that
from our perspective okay from our
perspective
in the west eating dogs is
strange it's it's weird it's odd just
like someone from another country might
look at our obsession with fast food and
find it sort of
peculiar and humorous and so they might
make jokes about it
and they do make jokes about it we
likewise might notice some of the
dietary habits in other parts of the
world and get our own chuckles out of it
so what i like fast food as much as the
next guy but it's not sacred
it's not some sort of hallowed sacrament
it is kind of weird that we eat so much
of it there are plenty of
funny things you can say about the fact
that we eat so much of it
that we spend so much of our lives in
drive-through lines
it's kind of sad and but also funny
there are things you could say there's
observations you can make about it
comedians make those observations all
the time there's ample material here for
jokes so have it
i don't see why we can't have the same
attitude and the same approach about
eating dogs or eating anything else that
people eat
here's the thing the people who are
trying to stop
us from telling any jokes that have
anything to do with race
will say that their goal is to have
greater inclusion
and racial harmony but their goal is
exactly the opposite
because the way to have inclusion and
harmony or something close to harmony as
close as you can get to it
the way to do that is to joke it is to
prod at the sacred cows it is to
see the absurdity in ourselves and each
other and laugh about it
you cannot ever be included in a group
be it a friend group or a country
if you demand that nobody jokes about
you that nobody can tell any jokes about
you
and you know that you're not really
included that that they don't really
consider you
one of them if they're not joking about
you
this is especially true for men i can
tell you if you're with a group of guys
and they're they're all making fun of
each other and ragging on each other and
often
if you've been around guys in this
environment the jokes can be
brutal i mean i forget about racial is
like
only the start of it this could be
brutal jokes to each other
but this is how they bond and everyone's
laughing and having a good time
and if you're in this group and you're
noticing this
and nobody is throwing any barbs at you
it's not because they all respect you so
deeply or they care
about you more than they care about each
other quite the opposite it means
they don't feel as comfortable with you
it means they don't like you as much
they don't know you like that they don't
consider you a friend they don't
consider you one of them
it is at the moment that one of them
turns to you and says hey dumbass
that's when you know you're a part of
the tribe that's when you know that you
belong
now i think this holds true at a much
larger level i think it holds true on a
national level
and and what it means is that the more
we stop people from
joking about each other the more we stop
people from
from uh from joking about each other the
more we stop them from fitting in
the more we stop them from being
included from getting along
so this is a very long way of saying
that jay leno is cancelled
so is megan mccain so as uh the other
woman i mentioned
all canceled canceled canceled cancelled
all of them
and we will leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
[Music]
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. biden claims
that women are better than men
at everything the senate confirms a man
who thinks he's a woman to a senior role
in the department of health
and that soccer lady whines at the white
house check it out on the michael
knowles show